[Musique]
ils étaient plus de 7000 coureurs à
s'être donné rendez-vous ce mercredi 18
octobre à Saint-Pierre pour la remise de
dossard des quatre courses du Grand Raid
qui débutera demain jeudi 19
octobre propriétaire de 95 % de forêt
publique le département consacre chaque
année 20 millions d'euros à l'entretien
et à la préservation des
sentiers notre but et notre objectif
c'est que notre terrain de jeu qu'on
doit préserver qui est donc notre petit
notre petit caillou la réunion un vrai
trésor pour nous passionnés de de de
nature et d'activité de pleine nature
surtout la randonnée qui est quand même
la première
activité de plein de nature sur sur
notre île on court toute l'année et du
fait de courir toute l'année ça cela a
forcément un impact sur sur les sentiers
sur la biodiversité terrestre mais aussi
marine les jeunes de l' NSS était
présent sur le stand du département afin
de sensibiliser les coureurs sur la
préservation des espaces
naturels vous aimz votre terrain de jeu
que ferez-vous pour le préserver éduquer
oui l'éducation la transmission le
respect de tout passe par l'éducation la
jeunesse c'est non seulement c'est ceux
qui vont nous relever s'ils ont une
bonne éducation une bonne transmission
normalement ils devrai à leur tour
pouvoir faire une bonne transmission 165
km et 1000 m de déniv POS le départ de
la diagonale des fou aura lieu à 21h ce
jeudi 19 octobre quoi qu'il arrive
amusez-vous c'est le plus important et
bonne course à
tous